sam millinger he covers Kansas City
sports covers the Kansas City Chiefs for
the Kansas City Star Kent city.com and
the great common miss joins us on the
program good morning Sam how are you I'm
good
I'm good how are you I'm good these
talks have been kind of quiet with
Patrick mahomes which i think is good
but well first of all are they going on
yeah okay what it what is the sort of
the parameters here or the framework
here from each side of what they hope to
get let me start with the Kansas City
Chiefs what would be ideal for them to
get with Patrick mahomes long-term
employment of Patrick that is the goal
from the team for sure
III think that you know these talks have
been going on and I think that there's a
mutual there's mutual ground here
Patrick wants to be with the Chiefs the
chiefs obviously want him here long term
he'll be the highest-paid player in the
league you know I think that's that's a
wrap it's just a matter of structure and
figuring out exactly how to do it but
also if you're Patrick mahomes in his
agent what is your strategy of how long
and how much and then get that second
you he'll get another contract - that's
gonna be a big one before he's even 30
yeah and and I want to be clear like
Chris Cabot who is you know leading the
leading in the negotiations on Patrick's
side he's been he's been nice quiet you
know the the insight that I'm getting is
from other people in the business and it
is tantalizing for them because this is
a possibility to really change future
negotiations I mean the thing that comes
up when you talk to anybody in football
really agents especially is nobody has
ever had this kind of leverage
you know League MVP the first year Super
Bowl MVP the second year of playing
obviously sent the first year and and
he's 24 years old he's changed a
franchise kind of turned them from you
know sort of a perennial postseason
heartbreaker to you know a possible next
dynasty and and that she's so he's got
them you know he can ask for whatever he
wants and that's what people keep
talking about like is this the time that
that something gets tied to a percentage
of the salary cap you know that's
something that some agents have wanted
a long time and teams have always
resisted is it just a full guarantee I
know Kirk Cousins did that a couple
years ago but this you know Patrick's
numbers would obviously dwarfed that so
it's it's sort of I think what people
around the game were looking at is not
just the bottom line money which will be
enormous but it's also what what kind of
new precedents can be set that can help
other players but you if you tie it to
the salary cap and if I'm going to
follow what you pointed out in your
column let's say the salary cap goes
down 25% Oh
mahomes is salary then will go down but
then it will go up exponentially with
the long term possibilities with the new
TV deal in gambling involved in the NFL
correct yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah
there's risk on both sides if you do
that for sure what kind of money though
can you overpay for Patrick mahomes I
just I feel like all the rules are
different with him you know when you
look at his age and just what he's been
able to do there's no I tend to think
about things like this like okay if if
he turns out to not be as good as we
think he is right now if he just becomes
a good quarterback not a transcendent
one what is the reason and I can't
figure it out you know what I mean like
is it his physical talent like obviously
no is it is his mind obviously no is it
work ethic you never know how money can
change somebody but there's nothing in
his background or sort of his
personality that makes you think he's a
risk to you know sort of start mailing
it in you know once he gets paid the
only thing that would concern me though
Sam is we've seen this before where
quarterbacks get their money and you
know Seattle built a team that was on
the verge of a dynasty her mini dynasty
because of Russell Wilson where he was
drafted and how much he was making we've
seen this with you know teams trying to
draft a rookie quarterback get him to
play and then build the team around him
Kansas City's gonna have some big ticket
items and Chris Jones who could have
been the MVP of the Super Bowl you know
he might be a guy who you know pass to
pay the price for mahomes getting his
money yeah there's no question I mean
that they've got these are smart points
that you're make and they they you know
you know how these contracts work like
you can actually create some short-term
contracts pay or some short-term payroll
space
with a long-term deal with with Chris
Jones right like he's on the cliff for
what is it 16 million something like
that under the franchise tag you can
create some short-term cap space by
giving him a long-term deal but the the
Chiefs are in a really you know it's a
good problem it's one of these good
problems to have because they're paying
good players but you know there was a
moment I think a week or two before the
draft where the Chiefs have a hundred
and seventy seven dollars not a hundred
seventy seven grand a hundred and
seventy seven dollars it could not go
out to eat as in a big group with that
so you know they think they've got some
hard decisions but again I mean these
are the problems that you want right
like you want the problem to be like how
can we tie up you know the best player
in the game long term sam millinger
Kansas City Star joining us on the
program take me back to the draft and
when the Kansas City Chiefs were moving
up and then you had Alex Smith I believe
coming off a Pro Bowl season and all of
a sudden you're drafting a quarterback
there what did the look what was the
local media reaction in Kansas City you
have to remember that in Kansas City it
had just been a long line of somebody
else's backup quarterback they were
starting for the Chiefs it was Trent
Green it was Steve de Burgh it was Steve
Bowen oh it was Joe Montana for you know
two glorious seasons in the 90s but they
had not drafted a quarterback in the
first round since the 1983 draft but
they came out of that with Todd
Blackledge all other people got
hall-of-famer so it this had been a cry
I mean it was like almost part of Kansas
City's you know it's almost imbedded in
Kansas City as a sports fan is like why
the hell won't the chief draft a
quarterback in the first round and when
they it right before that draft you know
all these smoke screens that team to
throw out but there was there some talk
that that they wanted a linebacker to
stop the run and and you know short term
just for that next season maybe that
would have been the smarter move you
know somebody just stopped the run cuz
we certainly saw how that ended in the
playoffs but you know when they traded
up and it was you know not just a
quarterback a lot of people assumed it
might be deshaun Watson there right and
he was you know the national
championship quarterback against Alabama
and the two minutes all that all that
stuff but when they took Bascom Holmes
now you take a
a really big swing right now you're
really going for the highest ceiling you
can get I mean it was just I think there
was a nervous energy you know like oh my
god it finally happened I hope it's the
right move but it was also like finally
at least at least they're taking their
move and you know this covering drafts I
don't believe anything until you see
that day of or
right before maybe the day before and I
had an NFL scout who said your guy
mahomes is moving up now I said my guy
because I would come in every Monday and
tell my guys you've got to watch this
guy I don't know if he can play in the
NFL but he's as fun as any quarterback
I've ever seen and Mike's NFL scout says
your guys moving up the draft board I go
what do you mean he goes oh no he's
going top 15
I go you got all these people say that
he's you know he's like far but he's you
know he's gonna be a little bit more of
a project here like what happened where
it's still an inexact science when we
look at these quarterbacks and and
Holmes is one of those classic cases of
he was he was there everybody could have
you know seen this or maybe had him and
what was it about him that we missed out
on I think that it was a lot of surface
stuff to be honest with you I think that
you know if you go back in time to 2017
you know the air rate that was that was
a knock you know nobody had ever come
out of Texas Tech or that system and and
and had a great career there was some
questions about you know his handling of
a huddle or is it his grasp of a
playbook that kind of thing because what
you see on tape we see on film is
outrageous
it is now in the NFL and then it
certainly was at Texas Tech but you sort
of wonder you're just used to guys like
that that put up these big numbers just
not being able to do it in the NFL for
whatever reason I think one thing that
doesn't show up on tape with these you
know can these outrageous highlights
it's how smart he is and and how quickly
he can grasp things and how quickly he
can absorb it own it and then move on
you know what I mean like this is it is
different with him for sure you
surprised the Chiefs drafted a running
back that huh I was a little bit look I
thought that they should have gone
defensive back with that first pick and
then
and your running back later I just I
believe that you can get value a little
bit later on at that position but you
know Clyde Edward two-layer he is he is
something different and and when you
watch him you know during the season
stamp by stamp throughout a whole game
and then certainly like you know the
highlight tapes now I mean you can see
exactly what the chief saw in him and
and how he is an unbelievable fit for
that system if he can protect you know
if you're gonna play running back you
got a pass protect you're gonna be able
to protect the franchise but assuming he
can he can learn that part of it
it's just a absolutely ridiculous fit
they're gonna be tough to stop Sam I
can't help but go back to that knee
injury with my homes and what we thought
at the time and what it could have meant
I mean that that was that was historical
in what it did for the franchise and a
quarterback and other quarterbacks and
you know legacy like it it was pretty
that was a big moment there yeah it was
horrific I mean right when that happened
I can't remember if it was McCall
Hardman or Tyree killed one of the
receivers am I've been DeMarcus Robinson
anyway taking their helmet off after
they see what happened and let me see
what what that knee looked like taking
their helmet off and slamming it into
the ground and when you see that kind of
reaction you know you think this is more
than a sprained knee and then when you
hear dislocated kneecap it's kind of
makes you cringe you know what I mean
but then it was weird like I remember
he's he's starting to walk off the field
and he's got arms around and and he's
being helped and then you know damned if
by the time he gets to the 15-yard line
it's not walking on his own and it was
just like what it like this guy is just
different and then you hear these got
like double-jointed knee or some
absolutely insane it should be fun to
see now does this Kansas City try to
wrap him up before dak Prescott and
deshaun Watson or after well the better
question is the Cowboys the Texans want
to get those deals done like Patrick's
gonna get his money regardless I don't
think they really care what these good
stuffs am thanks for joining us all
right thanks guys
that's a Mellinger and City Star